First of all, man,
who says that I am a house slave?
I mean, I'm not even home most of the time.
I'm out having a coffee with a friend
or I'm out at the gym or I'm doing something that I like to do.
I can go shopping. I can do whatever I want,
whenever I want. Just because I'm a traditional wife and mum
doesn't mean that I stay home and slave around all day.
And even if I was a house slave,
I think that I would much rather be a slave to my husband and my kids
than a slave to my boss
who doesn't care about me and could replace me tomorrow.
Being a mum, being a wife, irreplaceable.
I mean, sure,
my husband could go and get married again,
but it will never be to the mother of his kids.
And is this truly what we've come to in this day and age
where your entire worth is based on your job?
Everything that I do in our home is considered a job.
My husband does his part and I do my part.
Just because he's the one out physically bringing the money in
doesn't mean that I'm not also earning a paycheck in my own way.
I'm not hiding behind my job.
I don't have to go out there and be a boss, babe,
because I know what I bring to the table.
And I hate to say it and be controversial,
but Most men don't actually want a boss babe.
That's outdated. I mean,
men want someone that's soft and feminine.
I can say if I was a man,
I would personally like to come home to what my husband comes home to.
Comes home to the kids bathed,
fed, a clean home,
a nice dinner. I'd rather have that as a man
than come home at same time as my wife comes home from work
to a probably messy house,
chaos everywhere.
I spend one hour with my kids before they go to sleep and that's it.
That is not the true definition of life.
I mean, everyone has their own opinions,
but this is just what works for us.
And I'm not sure if people have heard of divorce.
Um, if he was to leave me,
I would have half and he would have half.
So I think I'd be okay. I also had a career before I met him.
I was not a child bride. I wasn't forced into this marriage.
It's something that I chose to do.
And I think that's true power
is being able to choose what you want to do with your life.
Most women don't work because they want to.
Most women work because they have to.
So that's just my opinion.
But, you know,
you can do it that what you please.